okay so uh
when i when i'm doing this i i don't
want to grab his arm
and you see that there's nothing is
happening nothing is happening
then finally it's on you see that
so i'm coming around nothing nothing is
happening nothing is happening nothing
is happening nothing's have now songs
[Music]
and also nothing happening that's where
he that technique is gonna fall apart
okay so uh the first
the first part is always always get his
balance
and always start the circle
so and i'm going to take this line
i'm going to do with his elbow boom okay
now when i'm here
i'm not going to grab this arm i'm going
to use the centrifugal energy
energy was going that way and when i
turn it that energy creates a friction
as i'm bringing it back towards me okay
it's not that i'm going here
and i'm fighting it the energy is going
that way and i'm keeping it going
so i'm here
and boom keep the center of the ground
going
but i'm keep it going on this spiral
so boom right into it
it's going around on a spiral
okay that's my first thing
and what i'm going to do is take that
spiral
into the into the lock so the lock is
already on you see
i'm not going here pulling us off and
then
now it's on
i'm going to take the body the body
control
goes right into the into the lock
so slack is being taken out black being
taken out slack being taken out
[Music]
boom on
foam on
so
right there
[Music]
different
different body
on
so here is where at this point i have
uh tension through his wrist joint
his elbow his shoulder and so it moves
his center
so this is where i have to be
what i'm doing instead it's supposed to
just here
come around slack slack slacks like
slack and now um
[Music]
is i'm taking the elbow
into that relationship so the elbow goes
and there there it is right there that's
where it's on
so i'm using this part
to get this part then it's on
oh that elbow goes there
so if i pull this now it's not going to
be on it has to go forward
you see into the final
spot into the final right there
that's what i'm looking for oh
[Music]
and i'm just doing that by doing an ikea
adhesion
inside his body letting the elbow go
into position there
oh
[Music]
okay so like from here you can't
understand how he would end up like this
okay especially if you're going down
going down going down it's never going
to happen
because you're having the elbow go
backwards
so when you're here here here's your
check let's say he wants to turn into me
he'll he'll find it hard to do because
i'm controlling the elbow
if i try to make this thing go down like
this then he's going to turn
he can turn it so that's not even where
my
move is supposed to go okay so i'm over
here and then here
pushing out pushing out okay
and and don't you want to bring it back
because you think he goes backwards
no he he's going to go forward he's
going to go forward
okay so let's watch his
his relationship to his rib cage so
here's
here's what you want to do but the
problem with that is the hand is forward
i need this relationship instead
so i'm bringing this forward forward
don't wait don't don't get eager and
start pulling it back
keep it going forward forward forward
there it is right there
do you see so it's further up on the
spiral
right and then you have the lock pass to
the wrist
so boom just be patient
keep it going forward forward forward
and then it'll pass it and then you'll
see
that i can get that to lock out
forward forward forward forward
and i'm just showing you that it's in
his lay down
i'm just showing you look same exact
thing same exact thing
you see the arm does not want to go that
way
and that's exactly what i'm doing that
his body can absorb
won't be patient be patient around there
okay and then you see you're in the same
exact thing
over here
[Music]
okay